[Music]
the top brass from the oakland days are
in las vegas scouting possible sites for
a new baseball stadium sports director
chris matthews joining us with the
latest
and what's this oakland's mayor taking a
few jabs at us here chris
kirsten how does that happen we'll talk
about that in just a minute but who
takes shots at the sports entertainment
capital of the world
well the mayor of oakland apparently
does tuesday now the oakland city
council approved their latest term sheet
on a multi-billion dollar stadium plan
but the a's weren't impressed saying
they won't move forward with the latest
non-binding binding or other term
agreement
but one thing the mayor does say today
don't expect concessions and public
money to be thrown at the a's like the
city did to lure the raiders back from
los
angeles we are never going to do a
raiders deal again
we have all lived through the nightmare
of that
we have learned many lessons from bad
sports deals of the past
we will not repeat those those mistakes
we are going to do a deal that does not
leave future generations of taxpayers on
the hook
all right she's referring to the
multi-million dollar stadium expansion
called mount
davis that the city is still paying for
major league baseball has given the a's
and the city a timetable for an
agreement now the mayor didn't say
exactly when that was
but she does say her staff is working to
meet every single deadline
and before she concluded her press
conference today she took a little shot
at vegas
we are so excited we are ready to keep
playing we're at bat and we believe that
it is time for us to keep going
on this visionary project
just saying las vegas is going to be
106 degrees this week
and there is nowhere that can offer
these spectacular views well apparently
mayor schaff hasn't been to las vegas in
a while but most of the world agrees
that las vegas
is a pretty spectacular city we'll
continue to follow the age and their
visit to las vegas they're here today
and tomorrow
my colleague rob futrell has more on
possible stadium sites if the a's indeed
make a move here the owner is actually
in town with dave cavall we'll have more
on that
coming up a little bit later